COMMUNICATIONS COMMITTEE WILL
NOT COME TO ORDER. ARE WE READY
TO BEGIN WITH. SOMEBODY CAN
GIVE ME A. I'M OKAY HERE WE
READY TO START. MEMBERS ARE
READY. SIR MODERATOR READY ARE
WE BEING TELEVISED. OR WEB
STREAMS OR WHATEVER. OKAY OKAY
VERY WELL THE SENATE ENERGY
UTILITIES AND COMMUNICATIONS
COMMITTEE WILL NOT COME TO
ORDER GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYBODY
IN RESPONSE THE COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY ANSWERING TO PROTECT
THE PUBLIC. LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GAP GATHERINGS AND
IT HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING
AND FACE COVERING GOT
GUIDELINES. IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS
MADE NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO
NORMAL PRACTICES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE. ACCESS TO
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS. TO THE
EXTENT THE SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. AND WE WILL
BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR
ALL THE M. INDIVIDUALS WAIT
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT. THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE
IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT
NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER.
IS. 877-226-8164 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT TWO
TWO TWO THREE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE AND FOR THE-
ENERGY CHILES COMMUNICATIONS
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY A MONARCH
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO
FOR SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
PRESS THIS IS ONLY ONE TIME AND
WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR
TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER
THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT ONCE
YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER
YOU WILL WAIT FOR THE QUEUE FOR
THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU WILL BE
MUTED. AND YOU ARE NOT AN MUTED
I'M SORRY YOU WILL BE ON MUTED
AND YOU ARE NOT READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE
THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING AND
HEARING PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY EVENTUAL
INDIVIDUAL WHOSE DESTRUCTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETINGS MEETING SERVICE OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESS. AND TO CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IN AS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY.
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE JUST INTO
THIS. NEW TECHNOLOGY SO PLEASE
BE RESPECTFUL PATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
WE HAVE TWO BILLS ON THE AGENDA
TODAY WE HAVE ONE BILL ON
CONSENT A. B. TWO FOUR TWO BY.
SIMPLY MEMBER HOLDEN. I WILL
NOW ESTABLISH A QUORUM CLARK
COULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WESSEL PRESENT WESSEL PRESENTS
DOLLY HERE DOLLY HERE BECKER.
FORGES PORGES PRESENTS.
BRADFORD BRADFORD HERE. DOT
HERE DON HERE. AIKMAN. EIGHT
MEN HERE. GONZALEZ HERE CONSOL
IS HERE. HELLO. WELL HERE
HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG HERE.
MCGUIRE. MAN THIS WILL BE A.
THIRD HERE STERN HERE. KERRY
HAVE CORN. VERY WELL- WE WILL
I'D LIKE TO SEE IF WE CAN ACT
ON THE CONSENT NOW THE CONSENT
IS A B. TWO FOUR TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN CAN I GET
A MOTION FOR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. WE HAVE A- MOTION BY
SENATOR DOLLY- THE MOTION IS TO
APPROVE THE CONSENT CALENDAR
PLEASE CALL THE BUCKLER PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. PHOTO DEPARTMENT
EIGHTY TWO FORTY TWO BY SOME
MEMBER HOLDEN CONSENT WESSEL.
WESSEL HI DOLLY. DOLLY HI
BECKER. PORGES GORGEOUS HI
BRADFORD. BRADFORD I DON. HI
TODD HI EIGHT MEN. EIGHT MEN I
CONSULT THIS. CONSOL IS FINE.
GROW. GROSS HI HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG HI MY CHOIR. MAN
RUBIO. RUBIO I STERN AFTER NINE
STERN I. SURE YOU HAVE ELEVEN
EIGHTIES. VERY WELL THANK YOU
THAT BILL WILL BE- THAT BILL
HAS ENOUGH TO GET OUT BUT WILL
HOLD HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. WE'RE GOING TO
BEGIN WITH THE FIRST BILL A. B.
FIVE THREE SEVEN BY
TO COMMUNICATIONS WORLD
WIRELESS TELECOMMUNICATIONS AND
BROADBAND. FACILITIES WELCOME
SOME REMEMBER QUIRK. YOU MAY
BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY. YES
THANK YOU START SHARING
SENATORS. NINE THANK YOU CHAIR
FOR DISCUSSING THE BILL WITH ME
EARLIER TODAY- SO THE BILL
ITSELF IS A CLARIFICATION OF
THE BILL THAT IS OF THE RULES
THAT ARE IN. OUR STATUTE RIGHT
NOW WHICH IS THAT THERE IS A
CERTAIN TIME LINE AND THE
COUNTIES HAVE TO APPROVE IT OR
DISAPPROVE OF IT WITHIN THAT
TIME LINE- THEN IF THEY HAVEN'T
ACTED IT'S DEEMED APPROVED AND
THE PERMITS MUST BE ISSUED.
AGAIN THEY CAN- BOTH AGREED AND
ISSUED THE PERMITS OR THEY CAN
DISAPPROVE OF NOTHING STOPS
THEM FROM DOING THAT. SO WE
HAVE A PROCESS WE'RE TRYING TO
DEFINE IT. THE TIME LINES THAT
WERE SET UP IN THE ORIGINAL
BILL OF THAT SUPERSEDED BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WE'RE ALSO
LINING THOSE. I AM VERY
GRATEFUL THAT THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WORKED WITH US ON
THIS PANEL. AND WHILE THEY
OPPOSE THE ORIGINAL BILL
INCLUDING AND ALSO A BILL THAT
YOU AND I RAN. OUT TOO CLOSE TO
ALSO WORK IN THIS AREA- THE-
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS HAVE
DROPPED THEIR OPPOSITION. THAT
WAS DIFFICULT WE HAVE TO GET
THEM TO AGREE TO EVERY COMMA
EVERY PERIOD EVERY WORD. AND I
WAS THEREFORE SURPRISED WHEN
THE STAFF A COMMITTEE STAFF
SAID THAT WE HAD PRECLUDED
LOCAL GOVERNMENT FROM THE
JUDICIAL- REVIEW. CURRENT LAW
ALLOWS FOR THIRTY DAYS FOR THEM
TO APPLY FOR A JUDICIAL REVIEW
THAT WAS NOT DEEMED O HAVE
BEEN CHANGED. HOWEVER IN VIEW
OF THE CONCERN OF THE COMMITTEE
I'M QUITE WILLING TO GET
TOGETHER OTHER BILL SPONSORS
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE
STAFF AND GET AN AGREEMENT. IF
THE CURRENT BILL DOES NOT
PRECLUDE THE- IF THEY CAN
CONVINCE US THAT THE CURRENT
BILL PRECLUDES THAT. OR WE
COULD CONVINCE THEM THAT THE
CURRENT BILL DOESN'T BUT WE CAN
GO FROM THERE IF WE ARE QUITE
HAPPY IF WE CANNOT COMMIT. IF
COMMITTEE STAFF. ARTIST
BELIEVES THAT- DESPITE WHAT THE
LAWYERS ARE SAYING THAT. WE
HAVE PRECLUDED IT I AM QUITE
HAPPY TO ADD CLARIFYING
LANGUAGE. AND AGAIN THAT WOULD
HAVE TO BE WORKED OUT WITH BOTH
SIDES BOTH THE SPONSOR THE
LEAGUE OF CITIES AND OF COURSE
WE WOULD WORK WITH YOU AND YOUR
STAFF. SO WITH THAT- I WOULD BE
QUITE HAPPY TO BRING THE BILL
FORWARD I PLEDGE THAT IF WE
DON'T GET AGREEMENT FROM ALL
SIDES THAT I WILL NOT. MOVE THE
BILL OFF THE SENATE FLOOR ALL
MAKE IT TO YOUR BILL. I
ANTICIPATE WITH A FEW WEEKS
WORK AND AGAIN I SAY A FEW
WEEKS BECAUSE WORKING WITH
LOCAL GOVERNMENT WE GOT EVERY
DOT. EVERY WORD OKAY SO WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO DO THAT AGAIN
AS WE- EXAMINE WHAT STAFFORD
SAID. AND IF AGAIN IF THEY
INSIST ON CLARIFYING LANGUAGE
WERE QUITE HAPPY TO DO THAT
IT'S JUST IT'LL TAKE A LITTLE
WHILE TO DO IT. SO THAT'S WHAT
I PROPOSE TO DO WITH THE BILL-
IF YOU AGREE TO PASS IT OUT
TODAY. WELL WE WILL DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO ANSWER THE
CONCERNS OF COMMITTEE STAFF.
THANK YOU TO SO I UNDERSTAND
YOU HAVE SPEAKERS OR CAN
ORGANIZE PRESENTATION AND WE
HAVE. AN ORGANIZED OPPOSITION
TO AND- THERE ARE TWO IN EACH
CATEGORY ON BOTH. AND I I'M-
GONNA SET ASIDE THREE MINUTES
TOTAL FOR EACH WHICH WOULD GIVE
EACH SPEAKER- A NINETY NINETY
SECONDS OR MEET THE MINUTE AND
A HALF TO MAKE THEIR
PRESENTATIONS- SO WE'RE GONNA
ASK THAT WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN
WITH THE- THIS THE ORGANIZED
PRESENTATION SUPPORT WE HAVE
NICK. NATE SOUL OF FROM CUT
CROWN CASTLE FOLLOWED BY
FEDERAL NAVA- THESE FEATURE A
COMMISSIONER AND CHAIRMAN OF
THE LITTLE LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION SO- MODERATOR CAN WE
CHECK TO SEE IF- NASAL OF IS ON
THE LINE. YEAH LATE SOW UP
HERE ON BEHALF OF CROWN CASTLE
THANK YOU ASSUMING THE RECORD
SHARE WEBSITE WITH COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR YOUR YEARS OF
COMMITMENT JOKES ALREADY
BROADBAND EXPANSION IN
ACCESSING CALIFORNIA. WE SHARE
YOUR GOAL AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE
PROUD TO SPONSOR EIGHTY FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN BECAUSE IT WILL
ALLOW HIGH SPEED INTERNET
PROJECTS TO BE COMPLETED IN
MONTHS INSTEAD OF YEARS.
CALIFORNIA ALREADY HAS PERMIT
SHOT CLOCKS IN PLACE FOR
BROADBAND PROJECTS THANKS TO
ITS ON THE RECORD HE B. FIFTY
SEVEN FROM TWENTY FIFTEEN THIS
LAW HAS BEEN WORKING WELL AND
HAS HELPED PREVENT PERMIT
DELAYS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL. THIS
BILL SIMPLY UPDATE CALIFORNIA
LAW TO REFLECT THE NEW FEDERAL
TIMELINES THAT WERE RECENTLY
ADOPTED SOLAR SHOT CLOCKS ARE
CONSISTENT. AND ALSO PROVIDE
CLARITY AROUND WHEN THE SHOT
CLOCK STARRED IN THE PROCESS.
AT THE CONCLUSION OF THE SHOT
CLOCK. FIVE SEVEN THE RIGHT
BALANCE THAT PRESERVES THE CAN.
BY A SHOULD TO YOU WHATEVER
PROCESS THEY WANT TO EVALUATE
BROADBAND PREVENTS. AND IT
ALLOWS THEM TO APPROVE OR DENY
THE BROAD BAND- BUT- THAT ALSO
HAS ENHANCED PROTECTIONS FOR
PROJECTS IN THE RIGHT OF WAY.
THIS IS WHAT LOCAL GOVERNMENT
GROUPS LIKE THE LEAGUE OF
CITIES C. SACK AND RC RC OR
NEUTRAL. ALL THE BILL DOES IT
MAKE SURE THAT CITIES MAKE A
DECISION TO APPROVE OR DENY A
BROADBAND PREVENT WITHIN
FEDERALLY MANDATED TIMELINES
WHICH ARE TYPICALLY TWO TO
THREE MONTHS DEPENDING ON THE
TYPE OF PROJECT. THIS BILL WILL
MAKE A REA DIFFERENCE FOR
CALIFORNIANS WHO DESPERATELY
NEED IMPROVED INTERNET ACCESS
FOR SCHOOL TELEHEALTH REMOTE
WORK IN COMMERCE. THAT WILL
LEAD TO COMMUNITIES GETTING
QUICKER ACCESS TO HIGH SPEED
INTERNET PROJECTS WHILE
MAINTAINING LOCAL CONTROL.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUED
DIALOGUE WITH THE COMMITTEE ON.
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS AS THE
BILL MOVES FORWARD. THANK YOU
NOW CAN WE HEAR FROM FEDERAL
NAVA. YES GOOD AFTERNOON- CHILE
STILL IN COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS PEDRO NAVA AND CHAIRMAN
OF THE LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION
HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF A. B.
FIVE THREE SEVEN. IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN THE COMMISSION ISSUED A
REPORT URGING CALIFORNIA TO
IMPROVE AND EXPAND ACCESS TO
DIGITAL GOVERNMENT SERVICES IN
THAT WE PORTENT TITLE A
CUSTOMER CENTRIC UPGRADE FOR
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT WE FOUND
THAT HIGH SPEED BROADBAND HAS
BECOME AN INTERNAL CHANNEL FOR
CALIFORNIANS TO ACCESS CRITICAL
SERVICES BOTH FROM THE
GOVERNMENT AND THE PRIVATE
SECTOR. YET IN OUR TWENTY
TWENTY ISSUE BRIEF ON
CALIFORNIA'S DIGITAL DIVIDE WE
FOUND THAT AS MANY AS TWO POINT
THREE MILLION CALIFORNIANS LACK
ACCESS TO BROADBAND AFFORDABLE
HIGH SPEED INTERNET IS NEEDED
NOW MORE THAN EVER YET FAR TOO
MANY CALIFORNIANS ARE LEFT
WITHOUT. A STATE WRAPS UP ITS
DIGITAL SERVICES PORTFOLIO IT
WILL BE CRITICAL TO ENSURE THAT
ALL CALIFORNIANS HAVE RELIABLE
BROADBAND CVERAGE EIGHTY FIVE
THREE SEVEN WOULD ADVANCE THE
COMMISSION'S RECOMMENDATION BY
INCREASED ACCESS TO RELIABLE
HIGH SPEED BROADBAND THE BILL
WOULD MAKE SURE THAT ALL LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS. UTILIZE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S BROADBAND
PERMIT SHOT CLOCKS SO HIGH
SPEED INTERNET PROJECTS CAN BE
DELIVERED QUICKLY TO OUR
COMMUNITIES EIGHTY FIVE THREE
SEVEN STRIKES THE RIGHT BALANCE
BY ALLOWING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO APPROVE OR DENY BROADBAND
PERMITS THE BILL JUST CLARIFIED
THAT IT MUST BE DONE IN A
REASONABLE TIME FRAMES THE
STYLISH BY THE FCC ON BEHALF OF
A LITTLE OVER COMMISSION. WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST. YOUR
EYEBALLS AND THANK YOU. THANKS
TIME INTO YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO- SPEAK- MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC. TO REGISTER
THEIR SUPPORT. IN FAVOR OF THE
BILL IF YOU ARE ON THE LINE AND
IN FAVOR. OF A. B. FIVE THREE
SEVEN WE ASKED YOU TO STATE
YOUR NAME. AND IF YOU'RE
REPRESENTING ANYONE YOURSELF
FOR ANY ORGANISATION. AND YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL IF IT'S IN
FAVOR- NO COMMENTS OTHER THAN
YOUR- POSITION. IN FAVOR OF THE
BILL IF YOU ARE IN FAVOR.
MODERATOR CAN YOU- PLEASE
QUEUE. MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
FAVOR OF A. B. A. B. FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN. FOUR COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO TECH COMMAND AGAIN ONE
ZERO. IN ATLANTA ONE HUNDRED
AND ONE HERE MIKE ABOUT. CHRIS
WROTE ON BEHALF OF THE ILICON
VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. LINE ONE
HUNDRED SIXTEEN YEAR MIKE IS
OPEN. FIND. ONE HUNDRED
SIXTEEN. BY EIGHTY TWO GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
REX W. HINE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS PROPERTIES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NEXT CALLER. WE HAVE A FEW
MORE- COMMENTS COMING THROUGH
ONE MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE
PROVIDE THEM WITH MY NUMBERS
EIGHT LINE NINETY EIGHT YOU'RE
MY COULD OPEN. THANK YOU MR
CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS JONATHAN
EHRENFELD WITH PTA THE TRADE
ASSOCIATION FOR THE WIRELESS
INDUSTRY AND STRONG SUPPORT.
NEXT CALL IN LINE AT. ONE
EIGHTY SEVEN. BUT AFTER NEARLY
ANY CONTENT OF THE TRAINING AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. WE HAVE TWO
MORE COMMENTS COMING THROUGH-
BLIND ONE HUNDRED SEVENTEEN
YEAR MIKE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MELANIE FIGUEROA ON BEHALF OF
VERIZON AND STRONG SUPPORT.
LINE ONE HUNDRED NINETEEN. A
GOOD AFTERNOON AS SENATORS MATT
REGAN REPRESENTING THE BAY AREA
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU. AND MISTER CHAIR
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT
THE TIME. WELL DO YOU HAVE ANY-
SUPPORTERS HERE IN THE GALLERY.
IN SUPPORT. OF A. B. FIVE THREE
SEVEN HERE IN THE GALLERY. OUR
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE I DON'T AND
NO ONE IS PRESENT ROOM ONE
TWELVE SO NO ONE THERE NO ONE
HERE INTHE GALLERY NOW WILL GO
TO ORGANIZE PRESENTATION. IN
OPPOSITION OF FIVE THREE SEVEN
I UNDERSTAND WE HAVE- ELLEN
ELLIE MARKS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
BRAIN TUMOR ASSOCIATION-
MODERATOR PLEASE. Q. MISS MARKS
TO MAKE FOR. ONE AND A HALF
MINUTES- OPPOSITION COMMENTS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ALI
MARKS I LIVE IN INDIAN WELLS
CALIFORNIA I REPRESENT
AMERICANS RESPONSIBLE
TECHNOLOGY AND NATIONAL
NONPROFIT. AS DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA BRAIN TUMOR
ASSOCIATION I'VE TESTIFIED TO
THE UNITED STATES CONGRESS ON
THE HARMFUL HEALTH EFFECTS OF
WIRELESS RADIATION. THE
NATIONAL INSTITUTE OF HEALTH
ARE PRETTY HEALTHY AGENCY HAS
PROVEN WITHOUT A DOUBT WIRELESS
RADIATION CAUSES CANCER PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY ARE BEING
IGNORED BY OUR STATE LEGISLATOR
BILL SUCH AS- AB FIVE THREE
SEVEN EXEMPLIFY OUR HOUSES
BECAUSE BRAIN SCANS PERFORMED
ON OUR FIREFIGHTERS WITH A CELL
TOWER IN THEIR STATION. SHOWED
SERIOUS ABNORMAL MRI IF
FIREFIGHTERS ARE EXEMPT WHY NOT
THE REST OF US ESPECIALLY OUR
CHILDREN WHERE IS THE FASTER
MORE AFFORDABLE MORE SECURE AND
COMPLETELY SAFE FIBER OPTIC
CABLE TO THE PREMISES WE ALL
PAID FOR TELECOMS ARE USING
THOSE FUNDS TO BUILD THIS
INFERIOR INFRASTRUCTURE. IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN YES WE HAVE
SEVERAL SHORTER SHOT CLOCK IT
DID NOT EXTEND TO DEEM THE PERM
REMEDY FOR FAILURE TO MEET THE
SHOT CLOCK UNDER THIS BILL IF
QUESTIONS REMAIN ABOUT AN
APPLICATION TELECOM TO PROCEED
WITH CONSTRUCTION OF TIME UP
THE PLANTS THAT. BOTH THE FCC
AND THE NINTH CIRCUIT FEDERAL
COURT AGREE THAT A CONSTRUCTIVE
MISS TELECOM SHOULD BE REQUIRED
TO GET COURT APPROVAL BEFORE
CONSTRUCTION THIS BILL
TRANSFERS THAT ACTION IN COURT
FOR THE CITY OR COUNTY WE
CONCUR WITH THE COMMITTEE ON
ANALYSIS RECOMMENDATION OF THE
AUTHOR AND THE COMMITTEE. MAY
WISH TO AMEND THE BILL TO
REMOVE LANGUAGE AUTHORIZING
CONSTRUCTION OF THE FACILITY
WITHOUT A PERMIT WE URGE YOU
NOT TO PASS THS ON PROMISES TO
AMEND BUT HOLD THE BUILDING
COMMITTEE UNTIL YOU SEE IT IN
PRINT WHAT YOU ARE. VOTING ON
THE DIGITAL DIVIDE AS A
CONSCIOUS DECISION BY TELECOM
NOT TO SERVE POOR COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE THE PEOPLE LIVING THERE
CANNOT AFFORD. ANOTHER THING
THE LEGISLATURE CAN. DO NOTHING
TO CLOSE THE DIGITAL DIVIDE. ON
BEHALF OF MEDICARE. EMPLOY UPON
YOU TO VOTE NO ON. FIVE SEVEN
THANK YOU THANK YOU I WILL GO
TO GARY WOULD FROM. FIRE KELLER
AND I BELIEVE HERE FOR A YOU.
I'M A PART OF A VERY WELL YOU
CAN YOU CAN BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE
READY R. JUST A POINT OF
CLARIFICATION I UNDERSTAND THAT
HANDICAPPED PEOPLE GET TWICE
THE TIME. HERE'S MY PLACARDS.
ALSO A RESTART YOUR TEN.
MINUTES YOU GET A MINUTE NAPS
ARE STARTING. TO GET A MINUTE
HALF HOUR RESTART YOUR TIME.
YEAH RIGHT. OKAY I'M I'M VERY
WOMEN'S WRITTEN U. TWO LETTERS
ABOUT THIS BILL ALREADY. AND BY
WAY OF BACKGROUND I'VE HAD
THREE PRESIDENTIAL
APPOINTMENTS- AND SEVERAL
OTHERS. AGAIN THE GENERAL
ENVIRONMENTAL AREA TWO OF THEM
IN THE WHITE HOUSE I'VE ALSO
BEEN INVOLVED IN LAW PROFESSOR
AT THE MAJOR. UC LAW SCHOOLS.
THIS LITTLE. TAKES AWAY THE
POWER OF CITIES TO DECIDE
THINGS THAT WERE GRANTED TO
THEM BY THE CONSTITUTION THE U.
S. CONSTITUTION GIVES THE
POLICE POWER OF STATES THE
STATE CONSTITUTION HAS GIVEN IT
TO THE CITIES YOUR LEGISLATION
WHICH WOULD TAKE AWAY THE POWER
OF DECISION. FROM CITIES AND GO
TO A PRIVATE CORPORATION IN
EFFECT. IS AN ATTEMPT TO CHANGE
THE CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION BY
LEGISLATION AND THAT'S NOT
GOING TO GET VERY FAR. AND IT'S
AN EXTREMELY ON ON LINE IS.
STILL TO TRY TO DO. THE BILL
CURRENCY EFFECT ON DESTROYING
THE VALUE OF THE PROPERTY. YOU
CAN IMAGINE WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
ONE OF THESE WHAT T. W. SKIP.
FUNCTION PUT UP IN FRONT OF
YOUR OF YOUR HOUSE. OR YOUR
NEIGHBOR'S HOUSE AND- OR IN
YOUR CITIES IN YOUR PARKS- THE
CITY TO CONTROL ITSELF TO USE A
POLICE POWER TO CONTROL HEALTH
AND WELFARE AFFECTS OF. THESE
SURE WTF TOWERS IT IS NOT GOING
TO BE EASILY CHALLENGED BY THIS
LEGISLATION. HERE ARE TWO
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF. LITIGATION
MOST OF IT PREDICTABLY
UNSUCCESSFUL IT WILL LEAD TO
ENORMOUS EXPENSES BY THE CITIES
AND THE COUNTIES BECAUSE THEY
ARE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO GET
INSURANCE AROUND THE INSURER S.
INSURANCE INDUSTRY HAS SAID
QUITE CLEARLY THAT THEY WILL
NOT. INSURE ANY INSTALLATION
HELLO RADIATING. B. M. F. AND-
THERE WERE OTHER TIMES SIR
PARDON YOU'RE OUT OF TIME. WE
APPRECIATE YOU YOU COME IN
WE'RE VERY HONORED TO HAVE YOU
HERE IN THE CAPITAL BY THE WAY
SO THANK YOU FOR COMING. AND WE
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE TO OUR COUNTRY. NOW WE
WILL GO TO THE GENERAL PUBLIC
I'M SORRY- YES- WILL GO TO THE
GENERAL PUBLIC AND ASK FOR
SPEAKERS TO STATE THEIR
POSITION ON THE BILL. ANY
AFFILIATION AND THEIR NAMES.
WILL BE COME HERE IN THE
GALLERY WE HAVE A GENTLEMAN
HERE WELCOME BACK SIR- YOU CAN.
STATE YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL
THANK YOU SENATOR HUESO MY NAME
IS PAUL GAVIN I'M WITH
CALIFORNIANS THAT KNOWS THAT
FTC EIGHTEEN DASH ONE THREE
THREE CANNOT PUT IN WORDS TO
THE TELECOMMUNICATIONS ACT THAT
ARE NOT THERE AND WE OPPOSE THE
BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND
NOW WILL- ANYONE ELSE IN THE
GALLERY. NO ONE ANYONE A ROOM
TWELVE. NO ONE IS PRESENT ROOM
TWELVE WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES FOR SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION. OF ROOM OF AB. FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN- MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE TAKE A CUE SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION OF A. B. FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN WE ASK FOR YOUR NAME YOUR
FILIATION AND YOUR POSITION ON
THE BILL. FOUR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO SPEC COMMAND AGAIN.
ONE THEN ZERO IN ATLANTA ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY ONE YOU'RE MY
KIDS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
SYDNEY **** I REPRESENT TWO
HUNDRED CONCERNED CITIZENS IN
SANTA ROSA 46% OF BOTH THAT AND
WE ARE VEHEMENTLY OPPOSED.
THANK YOU. THE LINE AT. ONE
HUNDRED TEN. ONE ONE HUNDRED
TEN HERE MIGHT HIT THE OPEN YES
HI MY NAME IS SARAH ANNA AND
I'M A MEMBER OF UNITED
EDUCATORS OF SAN FRANCISCO BUT
IN A PRIVATE CAPACITY I OPPOSE
AB. FIVE THIRTY SEVEN. LINE.
ONE HUNDRED EIGHTEEN. YES MY
NAME IS CONSTANCE ANDERSON.
PRESIDENT OF CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY AND MEMBER OF WIRED
WIRELESS RADIATION EDUCATION
AND DEFENSE. FORMALLY OPPOSED
AB THREE FIVE SEVEN WITH EVERY
FIBER OF MY BEING. A LINE OF
ONE HUNDRED TWENTY THREE. THANK
YOU MY NAME IS JOHANNA FINNEY
WITH CALIFORNIANS AGAINST
PREFERENTIAL TREATMENT OF THE
WIRELESS INDUSTRY STRONGLY
OPPOSING. EIGHTY FIVE THREE
SEVEN. BLIND AT NINETY NINE.
JENNIFER LOVE TOWARDS AND WE
CHECKED FOR SANTA ROSA AND I'M
ALSO A REGISTERED ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH SPECIALIST AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED BY THREE
SENATE. THE LINE. SEVENTY THIS
IS CATHERINE DOT EVER BE CENTER
ALIGNED TO NURSES FOR A HEALTHY
ENVIRONMENT- AND I AM A
REGISTERED NURSE WE OPPOSE AB
FACTORY SEVEN. LINE. ONE
HUNDRED EIGHT. NUMBER OF WIRED
WIRELESS RADIATION EDUCATION
DEFENSE AND I OPPOSE- MAYBE.
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN. THE LINE
EIGHTY EIGHT. MY NAME IS VICKY
FEVERS I REPRESENT THE EMF
SAFETY NETWORK MY ORGANIZATION
IS STRONGLY OPPOSED THANK YOU.
A LINE OF ONE HUNDRED FOURTEEN.
I GET AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
YVONNE NELSON I'M THE
COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF
AMERICA DISTRICT NINE AND I
TOTALLY OPPOSE. EIGHTY FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN. A LINE OF ONE
HUNDRED THIRTEEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON GOOD SORENSON WITH
UNIFICATION WORKERS OF AMERICA
DISTRICT NINE AND STRONG
OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN. BLIND. EIGHTY I
AM THE OLDEST TWO EIGHTY FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN I'M A AND GREAT
GRANDMOTHER. I LOST MY SON. AND
SEE THE CHILDREN FELL ILL I
THINK THAT THIS CAN HAPPEN IF
THERE ARE NO WORDS I NOTICE
PEOPLE WHO ARE FOR IT THEY'RE
GOING TO MAKE A LOT OF MONEY.
MEETING OUR CARS THAT ARE GOING
TO WE MADE HUGE AMOUNTS OF AIR
MATTRESS AND IT'S LIKE NOTHING
LIKE WE'VE EVER SEEN BEFORE
PLEASE. I APOLOGIZE FOR IT
THANK YOU. A LINE OF ONE
HUNDRED FOUR. SOME HARM CREDIT
TUTOR AND OWNERS TO HAVE
CHILDREN I DO FEEL STRONGLY
THAT THE DIGITAL DIVIDE MUST BE
CORRECTED I KEEP THIS EVERY DAY
IN MY WORK. AND HE CANNOT. BUT
THIS BILL EIGHTY FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN. PROBABLY BOTH CONDITIONS
THERE ARE GOING TO BE WITH. I
AM STRONGLY OPPOSED THANK. THE
LINE AT NINETY FIVE. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS CHERYL
MATTHEWS WITH AN EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR CALIFORNIA FOR
SAFE TECHNOLOGY WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB FIVE THIRTY SEVEN
THANK. FIND ONE UNDER TWENTY
TWO. YES DR SANDRA ROSS SAUDI
MEDICAL HEALTH AND HABITAT
SERIOUSLY OPPOSE AB FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN THANK YOU. ONE ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY. FIND ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY YEAR MIKE IS
OPEN. YOU HEAR ME HELLO YES WE
CAN AREA. THANKS I'M JANE
HERMAN COCHAIR OF THE P. IF YOU
USE SOCIAL JUSTICE COMMITTEE WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE IT BECAUSE IT
WILL INCREASE FIRE DANGERS AND
IT WILL NOT CLOSE THE DIGITA
GAP AT ALL. LINE. NINETY SIX.
GOOD AFTERNOON MARK GRAHAM ON
BEHALF OF THERE IS NO FEDERAL
LAW CODE RULE REGULATION OR
ORDER THAT PROVIDED DEEMED
APPROVED PROVISION IF YOU SAID
HE MISSES THE SHOT CLOCK AND
CROWN CASTLE IS LYING IT DOES
NOT TAKE YEARS TO GET A CELL
ANTENNA PERMIT IT TAKES MONTHS.
I OPPOSE WE OPPOSE. BLIND. ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR. HELLO MY
NAME'S LANDED HERSELF DIRECTOR
AND FOUNDER AND BACK SAMMY'S
ADVOCATING FOR A CHEMICAL AND
TOXIC C. C. R. TWO THOUSAND
MEMBERS STRONGLY OPPOSED THE
BAIL ON THE GROUNDS THAT IS
UNSAFE FOR CHILDREN TO HAVE
CELL TOWERS EMITTING RADIATION.
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN OUTSIDE HER
BEDROOM WINDOW. THANK YOU. AND
MEDICARE THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENT AT THE TIME. VERY WELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOW WILL
COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
COMMITTEE MEMBER COMMENTS. I
UNDERSTAND THERE'S BEEN SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT THE LANGUAGE IN
THIS BILL- REGARDING A SHOOTING
PERMITS AND ALLOWING
CONSTRUCTION- AND I KNOW THERE
HAVE BEEN INCIDENTS- IN IN
DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE COUNTRY
WHERE- REQUIREMENTS HAVE BEEN
MORE LAX WHERE YOU'VE ACTUALLY
HAD CONTRACTORS- PERFORM WORK
WITHOUT. CONTRACTOR'S LICENSE
OR EVEN PERMITS. AND SO WE I
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT. AS THIS
BILL MOVES FORWARD. THAT IT IT
DOESN'T EVADE THE PUBLIC SAFETY
PERMITTING PROCESS AND THAT IT
DOESN'T SEND MESSAGES TO THE
PUBLIC THAT THEY DID HAVE NO
LEGAL RECOURSE TO CHALLENGE-
THE CONSTRUCTION OF THESE
PROJECTS AS THEY COME AND I MAY
NOT. I UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
AUTHOR IS TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH
AND I AND I. ALSO UNDERSTAND
THAT. YOU KNOW AS LONG AS WE
HAVE COMPETITION OF BROADBAND
IN CALIFORNIA THERE THEY'LL BE
A HEALTHY MECHANISM THAT'LL
HELP TO ENSURE THAT WE KEEP THE
COSTS LOWER FOR THE USERS. WE
HAVE TO FIND A WAY THAT- CUTS
THROUGH A LOG JAM OF THE LANE.
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF A OF A
SYSTEM THAT HELPS WITH A
RESPONSE TO WILDFIRES A
RESPONSE TO PUBLIC SAFETY-
ARRIVING FASTER WHEREVER IT IS
THAT THEY'RE TRYING TO GET TO
PROTECT PUBLIC. AND THAT
COMMUNICATIONS THAT ARE
ESSENTIAL TO THE IMPROVEMENT
OUR ECONOMY AND GIVING PEOPLE
ACCESS TO IT. AND WE SAW DURING
THE PENN PANDEMIC THE
IMPORTANCE OF PROVIDING ACCESS
TO PEOPLE TRYING TO GET. THIS
SIMPLE ACCESS TO SCHOOL
CONSTRUCTION. THIS IS I BELIEVE
A STATE- FISH AT ISSUE TO THE
STATE THAT THE STATE NEEDS TO
ADDRESS URGENTLY WE NEED TO
FIND A WAY TO BRING IN THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE AND STATE AND
THE WAY IT'S GOING TO CUT COSTS
AND MAKE IT MORE ACCESSIBLE TO
THE PUBLIC. HI I'M GONNA ASK
THE I. O. I GET A CHANCE TO
SPEAK WITH THE AUTHOR EARLIER
AND I THINK WE AGREE ON A LOT
OF POINTS. JUST SIMPLY
CLARIFIED LIKE CLARIFYING
LANGUAGE. THE THAT INSURES THAT
ALL PROJECTS COMPLY WITH SAFETY
REQUIREMENTS INCLUDING DIG SAFE
REQUIREMENTS. PRIOR TO THE
START OF THE PROJECT'S
CONSTRUCTION. AND ALSO THAT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE A RIGHT
TO APPEAL FOR A JUDICIAL REVIEW-
AND THAT THAT PROCESS IS
PRESERVED PRIOR TO CONSTRUCT
CONSTRUCTION- CONSTRUCTION
CONSTRUCTION BEGINNING AND I
KNOW WE- THE YOU KNOW THE
DETAILS ARE ALWAYS VERY
IMPORTANT SO I'D LIKE TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR. THROUGH THIS
PROCESS I UNDERSTAND THIS BILL
WILL BE HEARD AT THE NEXT
POLICY COMMITTEE WE HAVE AMPLE
TIME TO IN THAT PROCESS JUST TO
PROVIDE THE CARE CLARIFYING
LANGUAGE AND YOU MAKE COMMENTS
TO THAT. IN YOUR OPENING
STATEMENTS BUT I JUST WANTED
YOU TO CONFIRM- SHOW- I HAVEN'T
HEARD ABOUT DICK SAFE BEFORE SO
FAR AS I KNOW WE DON'T
CONTRADICT ANYTHING THAT WOULD
INVOLVE DICK SAFE OR PROPER
CONTRACTING- AGAIN WE ARE MORE
THAN GLAD TO LOOK AT THAT WITH
YOU AND IF YOU AND YOUR STAFF
FEEL THAT- LANGUAGE IS NEEDED
THERE WERE MORE THAN HAPPY. TO
HAVE IT- THE SAME FOR JUDICIAL
REVIEW AGAIN. HI AND I BELIEVE
THE CITY'S WHEN THEY WENT
NEUTRAL ON THIS THE CITIES
COUNTIES. ALSO BELIEVE THAT
THAT'S IN THERE BUT IF- IF YOU
AND YOUR STAFF FEEL IT'S NOT
WE'LL PUT IN CLARIFYING
LANGUAGE YEAH I GUESS SO YEAH I
APPRECIATE THAT AND I JUST WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU KNOW AS-
WE'VE HAD INCIDENTS IN OUR
STATE THAT HAVE CAUSED.
WILDFIRES AND THERE HAVE BEEN
OTHER FIRES TIED TO. THE LACK
OF INFRASTRUCTURE SAFETY
OVERSIGHT AND INVESTMENT. I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THIS THE
BILL DOESN'T CUT INTO MAKE IN-
YOU KNOW THE SYSTEMS A PROVIDER
THESE IS YEAH I- I PLEDGE THAT
I WILL MAKE SURE THAT YOU AND
YOUR STAFF FOR FULLY SATISFIED.
WITH ANY CLARIFICATION LANGUAGE
YOU NEED OTHERWISE I'LL MAKE IT
A TWO YEAR BILL I CAN'T
GUARANTEE HOW LONG THAT WILL
TAKE SO IT COULD BE IF IT TAKES
A LONG TIME TO GET THE LANGUAGE
THAT IT BECOMES A TWO YEAR BILL
BUT I DON'T THINK THAT'LL BE
THE CASE I DON'T THINK IT'LL BE
THE CASE EITHER BUT I THINK WE
CAN WORK OUT THE DETAILS OF
FLEA. YEAH BUT I'M NOT SURE WE
CAN DO IT BEFORE THE NEXT
COMMITTEE HEARING BECAUSE WHEN
THE LAWYERS GET INTO THIS AND I
KNOW THIS FROM EXPERIENCE.
EVERY PERIOD EVERY COMMA EVERY
WORD WILL BE DISCUSSED YES AND
WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU
AND YOUR STAFF ARE SATISFIED
AND OTHERWISE IT BECOMES A TWO
YEAR BATTLE HI LARRY A PLUS OUR
PROMISE TO WORK THROUGH IT WITH
GREATER THAT. NIGHT HI SURE WE
CAN GET TO- A PLACE TO CLARIFY-
AND I DON'T THINK WE'LL BE TOO
SHAREHOLDERS BUT I UNDERSTAND
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING I'VE- I'VE
WORKED HERE LONG ENOUGH TO KNOW
THAT. CAN POTENTIALLY UNRAVEL.
BUT WE- WE PLAN TO WORK WITH
YOU THROUGH THIS SO. THAT YOUR
BILL COULD MOVE FORWARD. CENTER
RECOMMENDED YOU WANNA MAKE A
PROMISE JUST THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I JUST I DON'T KNOW IF
THIS BILL HAS BEEN MOVED YET
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO MOVE THE
BILL AND TO TAKE MISTER DOCTOR
QUICK FOR HIS WORK. AND JUST A
AS SOMEONE WHO SERVED ON THE
COURT FOR THE LAST EIGHT YEARS
TO KNOW HIM TO BE AN HONEST
BROKER IN THE PERSON OF HIS
WORD. AND HE WILL WORK
DILIGENTLY TO GET THIS TO A
PLACE I THINK IT'LL IT'LL COME
OFF THE SENATE FLOOR. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ARE THERE ANY OTHER
COMMENTS. IF NOT- DID YOU WANNA
MAKE ANY CLOSING COMMENTS
CENTER AWESOME YES- WE'RE MORE
THAN HAPPY TO WORK WITH CW WAY
SHOULD THEY DECIDE TO COME AND
TALK TO US. WE BELIEVE WE HAVE
THE ANSWERS TO ALL OF THEIR
QUESTIONS ONCE WE TOOK THE
AMENDMENTS THAT THE CITY'S
FASTEST TO TAKE PARTICULARLY
WITH REGARD TO SAFETY. ARM AS
FAR AS THE OPPOSITION- FROM.
THE- PEOPLE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
RADIO FREQUENCY WAVES I'M GOING
TO POINT OUT THAT. THOSE LAMPS
UP THEIR PRODUCE MORE ENERGY ON
YOU TENTE THAT THE CELL PHONES
TO. AND YOU YOURSELF. RADIO.
EIGHT HUNDRED- YOU GET LESS
THAN ONE LOT ONE BLOCK FROM A
CELL PHONE. SO IS THE AMERICAN
CANCER SOCIETY IS SAID THERE'S
NO STRONG EVIDENCE THAT
EXPOSURE TO R. F. WAVES CAUSES
CANCER THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THOSE ARE HIS CONCLUDING
REMARKS AND WE HAVE THEM MOTION
TO PASS A ROOFER CHECK TO THE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE. AND
FINANCE. CLARK COULD YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. EIGHTY FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN BISOLA REPORT DID
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE WESSEL BY WESSEL HI.
DOLLY BECKER. FORGES. BRADFORD
ALL RIGHT BRADFORD HI DOT ALL
RIGHT DONE I AIKMAN HI EIGHT
MEN I SINCE ALL THIS HI
GONZALEZ HI. GROSS. HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG HI MCGUIRE. WOMEN
RUBIO. REBEL HI STERN. SURE
THAT SEVENTIES. OKAY I THINK
BILL HAS ENOUGH TO GET OUT NO
NEEDS ONE MORE VOTE- OKAY THEN
WE'LL- BOOK THAT KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN- THANK YOU MISS WORK WE
WANT TO CALL ALL THE APPS
MEMBERS TO THE FLOOR TO FINISH.
THANK YOU EARLY ON THE BILLS
WILL TAKE UP A. B. R. TWO FOUR
TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR. IN
CASE ANYONE HERE ON THE FLOOR
HIS. NOT VOTED ON THAT BILL THE
CLERK- COULD YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. EIGHTY TWO
FORTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
HOLDEN'S CONSENT CALENDAR.
BACKER HI BECKER I. MCGUIRE.
MIKE WEIR I. MAN. KERRY HAVE
THIRTEEN VOTES OKAY WE'RE JUST
NEED MEN WILL PUT THAT BACK
THIS MAN. THE PRISON THIS IS
MEANT HERE. WELL WE'LL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN ON THAT ONE JUST
CASE WE'LL CHECK ON MEN I WILL
COME BACK TO A. B. FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN- TO- CALL THE OPPOSITE
MEMBERS ON A B. FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN CLERK. EIGHTY FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN BY SOME MEMBER PARK TO
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE. DOLLY. BECKER I. BAKER
I. BARGES. GROWTH GROSS HI.
MIKE WEIR. MAN STERN. NINE A
STIR. OKAY WE'LL GO AHEAD AND
CLOSE ROLE ON BOTH BILLS BOTH
BILLS GET OUT NOW. HE TERRY
WHAT HOMES.
WE'RE ACTUALLY
GOING TO TAKE A RECESS WE'LL
TAKE A TEN MINUTE RECESS AND
THEN WE'LL COME BACK. TO
INTERCHANGE VOTES ON BOTH BILLS.
WE'LL TAKE A TEN MINUTE RECESS.
IT IS RETURNING TO SESSION HERE.
WE ARE GOING TO CALL UP THE
BILLS AND- CALL THE OPS OF
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN
WITH THE CONSENT CALENDAR- A.
B. TWO FOUR TWO BY HOLDING.
PUBLIC UTILITIES BUT PLEASE
CALL THE OFFICE OF MEMBERS. A.
B. TO THE FORTY TWO BY SOME
MEMBER HOLDEN CONSENTS. MAN NO
VOTE. I HAVE NONE OF IT IS I'M
NOT VOTING. OKAY THE BILL IS
CLOSED ON THAT BILL GETS OUT
THIRTEEN EASTER. NOW A. B. FIVE
THREE SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
KIRK WORK BILL RELATED TO
COMMUNICATIONS WIRELESS
TELECOMMUNICATIONS AND
BROADBAND FACILITIES FOR PLEASE
CALL THE OPPOSITE NUMBERS A. B.
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN BY PHONE
NUMBER PORT. TO PASS REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE. DOLLY REQUIRE. MAN
HI MAN I. STERN. THAT'S TEN A
STIR. VERY WELL THE BILL IS OUT
THE CLOSER ROLE THE COMMITTEE
ON ENERGY UTILITIES AND
COMMUNICATIONS AND KNOWLEDGE
EARNED.